this is on camera I'm leaving babies
right now whoa back your head hold on
watch this one though
Julia versus Damien
Julia versus winner I've been playing
pole since I was abruptly about a fetus
you know I'm saying I used to take these
little globs on my mom's womb and I used
to hit that [ __ ] with the umbilical cord
you feel me didn't call me stick master
Dean for no reason ha ha ha pun intended
gangster you know I'm saying it's all
about how you hit the balls in the hole
so in the sweet we have a full dinner
now I'm not saying I'm the best pool
player alive but I'm saying I'm really
not that good
how long you been playing pool for uh
never oh right you suck I do growing up
I had a pool table in my room because um
that's right yeah
a tornado fool around my room before you
came that's our [ __ ] pretty much so the
story goes is that me my sister we just
share a room together but once my sister
went off to high school
she's like you know what mom's out I
really want my own room so I'm gonna
keep Julia out and I'm like whatever I
gotta go and so eventually my parents
told me to move into the game room slash
guest room and then in that room it had
a pool table and it had like a whole
bunch of like other random things in
there where people just didn't want
stuff in their room so I'll just toss
into my room so my room was basically
the junk room but I eventually made it
into tornadoes just how David described
it and filled it up with all my how you
got your pool skills no but we rarely
play pool though because um there was
too much stuff on top of Julia's
strength and Paul has to be the fact
that she's Cantonese she's a very strong
Cantonese woman presence and Astaire's
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of me but I have a will
of steel so you gotta break through
steel first to go ahead and get inside
the mushy Korean spoiled bean paste that
is the essence of my core
if you mrs. David I've made multiple
ones I get I get [ __ ] [ __ ]
who put that there
was that always thing I am the
Dumbledore of pool aka I am the Hermione
Granger of pool aka the Harry Potter aka
the Valda Mort of [ __ ] pool cubes the
chop duster of the stick aka I [ __ ]
your girl gangster did I do that on
purpose none of your [ __ ] business
just know it went in whenever I play a
sport I like to be extra competitive it
hasn't even if I'm not good at it it
doesn't really [ __ ] matter they don't
need to know that until they actually
played me pool is not a game that I'm
good at it requires a lot of skill and
just in general the game I I don't know
how to play it exactly I don't know
where to hit the ball how to hit it how
to make it into the corner pocket
business and that trick shot jump shots
all I know is that back in the day I
used to play the pool hall called
Sharkey's and it was [ __ ] ghetto
people got stabbed there robbed but for
some reason I wanted to be the cool guy
kicking with the people that went there
so uh did I learn how to play pool there
no I was too scared of getting killed
she made she is not intended at all
she was going for this right here and
this um-hmm that's how you do it is I'll
show the hustle this chick to hotel
lovelyz on her side like crazy oh my god
you guys thought you were so lucky we're
gonna call court really call pockets
next time you have to call pockets this
is one you have to call PI Julia used to
live in a pool hall it's absolutely true
her hair color matches the this felt the
felt table that she used to play they
used to call the [ __ ] blue steel pool
cubes that pocket what the [ __ ] all
right Julia [ __ ] it up I'm going to [ __ ]
it up at the end of the day when you
guys play sports make sure that you guys
know that it's all about winning if you
are second place you are an absolute
loser if you're a third place you should
have never even tried absolutely I'm not
saying I lost per say cuz I don't think
a winner can lose it's all about letting
the girl win because I'm a gentleman
like that you want to play again and we
call closets so you don't get luck watch
this [ __ ] right here watch this [ __ ]
right here
this right here is called a [ __ ] ass up
technique right here we're gonna hit
this green ball and we're gonna go for
yellow ball middle pocket Oh
basically I'm not how to play from the
guy named Petey winged snake outside
Sacramento California it was a dude that
was a convicted a serial rapist but I
trusted him he only tried to once stop
and talk though so I changed the flight
he no longer serial rapes gentle tables
have turned
Sierra Griffin's I learned I learned
corner pocket burn me [ __ ] dude I got
to tell you something like you know
aside from this [ __ ] a copy character
that I've been making up this whole time
I absolutely suck at pool we'll see what
happens when you got a call pocket son
does I know Genki puzzler this is some
real [ __ ] poker I'm a person who likes
to win with grace did I rub it in her
face
yes how you like that better Julia
what's up I told you I ain't get no
freebies in the house of poo but I talk
[ __ ] because I'm tight like that that's
different though you said you can't talk
[ __ ] haha I'm just an overconfident
human being for no reason